So, I went there,
I was hunting with the warriors.
I was gathering with the warriors.
Then they made me queen
and married me to the warrior.
To the best warrior.
Sarah Begum, thank you so much
for joining me, all the way
from the United Kingdom.
How are you?
I'm good. Thanks, Matias.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you very, very much for being here.
I really appreciate you taking the time.
You know, between all the traveling,
I don't know how much of that
you've been able to do during covid.
But, through all these extraordinary
experiences that you've had,
I'm especially curious
as young entrepreneur on my journey,
I'm trying to discover
what are different cultures in the world,
where there are different
experiences people are having.
And I can't think of anybody better
to tell me about these
extraordinary experiences than you.
So, Sarah, why am I so excited
to speak to you?
I'll let you tell them yourself.
Okay. So, I have travelled
to remote parts of the world,
living with indigenous tribes
and capturing their stories.
I've also survived dangerous places
such as the murder capital of the world,
slums and mostly undercover
to tell those stories, too.
So, we're going to have to spend
the majority of the time
hearing those stories,
because myself nor my friends
have gotten to be undercover in slums
and the murder capital of the world.
So, tell me first a little bit
about your entrepreneurial
and adventurous self.
Where does that passion for traveling
and finding those crazy adventures,
what did that stem?
Where does that come from?
Okay. So, growing up, I grew up
in a very multicultural environment
with friends from all over the world,
different cultures.
And I was always curious.
And I was curious about the world,
what else is out there.
At the age of nine,
I learned about deforestation
in the Amazon.
And it became my dream
to go there and save the trees,
and also to visit these tribes.
And at the age of 21,
I was studying television film
and journalism at a BA HONs
at a university.
But I didn't want to be
just another graduate
in a sea of other graduates.
I wanted to stand out from the crowd.
And so, during my final year,
I took a month out
to make my own film.
I won an award
that helped fund the ticket there.
I used my life savings
and also the university's resources,
take note.
And I decided
to follow my childhood dream.
So, I found a cameraman
from New York,
someone from Portsmouth
and an indigenous tribe
who lived primitively till this day.
And I just went there.
I planned the whole thing,
obviously, six months in advance.
And my goal was always
to make it a commercial piece.
My goal was also to get it
in the Cannes Film Festival.
So, I went there.
I was hunting with the warriors.
I was gathering with the warriors.
Then they made me queen
and married me to the warrior.
To the best warrior.
I didn't know what was happening.
I was thinking, "Wait a minute.
I thought they were just making me queen."
Because they had
to strip me naked as well
and make me one of them.
So, I became one of the tribe.
And that was actually
to create an alliance
so that I would spread their message
about protecting their land
from exploitation, because
there's a large oil reserve
where they live.
And they've had years
of fighting against the oil companies
to preserve their land
and the jungle and their home.
So, when I got back,
I finished my degree.
And then, I started working in TV.
I was taking under the wing
of a prominent film directors
and producers.
That one of Bear Grylls directors,
my role model,
Bruce Parry, contacted me.
That gave me hope.
And then eventually,
I managed to finish making this film,
this TV style, half hour documentary.
And I was the youngest person
ever to do that, to live with a tribe
and make a first film.
And funny enough,
as soon as I made this film,
it was accepted
into the Cannes Film Festival,
and that's where it premiered.
And it has been,
I'm still making royalties from it today.
So, it was acquired by Schultz TV
and many other online
broadcasting companies.
And yeah.
Talk about following your dreams, right?
Yeah.
Follow your dreams.
But that also made me realize
that this is what I want to do.
I didn't realize I was an explorer
and anthropologist, a journalist,
I had no idea because
I wanted to direct
the next godfather, you know,
and that didn't happen.
It just, life just took a different turn.
And I wanted to do something meaningful
with purpose in my life.
I just found it so exciting
going to these remote parts of the world,
learning about how these people live
and just giving them a voice.
And it helps them, it also helps me
because I feel fulfilled.
And over the years,
that's what I've been doing.
And jungles, I've been
to the Brazilian jungle as well,
and the Atlas Mountains of Morocco,
with the Native Americans
in the USA.
I did a road trip in three weeks,
18 states on reservations,
powwows everywhere.
In deserts, in the Jordanian desert,
the Wadi Rum desert
with the Bedouin tribe.
The Chai tribe in Ghana,
where I lived for years,
as an investigative journalist.
A year.
Yeah.
Wait, I have to hear about this,
with the Chai tribe in Ghana for a year.
What is that like?
So, I lived in Ghana for a year
as an investigative journalist
and I was with the Chai tribe.
I was the only British woman
at the time when they were showing me
the [--] festival, to commemorate
when the British
kicked them out of their hilltop homes
because they thought
they were committing human sacrifice.
It was really interesting.
They were calling upon their ancestors.
And we went to various sacred spots
for libation and prayer and chanting.
And it was really interesting,
really interesting.
Almost like a pilgrimage.
And so, I documented that.
By the way,
when you go and document
as an investigative journalist,
so you're both an explorer,
from what it sounds to me,
it's like you actually become one
of their own, right?
I mean, you marry a warrior
right in their own ceremony
and make an alliance with them,
and then you go
and you immerse yourself
in the culture
and of the Chai tribe in Ghana,
spending years of
an investigative journalist there,
but then also going
to all these different cultures.
And so, tell me a little bit about
this immersive experience
that you're having there.
Because, I'm imagining
that you're not just there
as a journalist with a microphone
and a camera all the time, right?
You're actually experiencing
what they're doing.
So, I don't always like,
I know that the camera's there,
but I'm not focusing on the camera.
When I'm there, I'm with them.
I focus on them.
And it's about human connection.
So, you have to connect
with them in an authentic way.
And I believe by immersing yourself
in a culture but completely letting go
with any preconceived ideas
or beliefs or values,
you get a genuine
and true depiction of their culture
and who they are
and how they live.
And that creates understanding
between you and their culture.
And then you're able to portray that
in a very honest way,
you know, and a very genuine way.
And I think if we all
were able to do that,
instead of having all these judgments
about cultures before
experiencing them ourselves
and before communicating with people
on a very honest level, you know,
then we'll learn how to respect others.
We can respect one another
and that creates diplomacy,
and that creates peace.
100%.
So, I completely agree.
I think it starts with a dialogue.
Before the dialogue,
it starts with respect
and truly respecting
and acknowledging
the other person's way of life,
which is different than
your way of life.
Yeah, but how can you respect
what you don't know?
Right.
What you don't understand, you know.
So, by having an immersive experience,
you learn to understand.
And by understanding,
you then develop that respect.
Right.
So, before we get to talking about,
you know, the different experiences
that you've had,
I have to hear about,
you know, being in the slums
and being undercover also
in the murder capital of the world.
But talk to me a little bit about,
but I have to hear your thoughts
a little bit about the impact.
And at the end,
you're going through
these immersive experiences
and obviously you're documenting
and showing them with the world.
And one of the insights
I hear from you is
in order to really respect
and really acknowledge their existence
and their, you know,
our joint livelihood,
we first have to know
and understand what they are like. Right?
And it's very hard to do that
when we're not
immersing ourselves with them.
So, how can we,
as a civilization, come together
without actually, you know,
without each person being able to go
and immerse themselves with,
you know, the Chai tribe in Ghana?
Watch documentaries.
When you see, I mean,
we live in a country
and in a world where
we are very lucky to meet people
from other parts of the world, you know.
Our neighbors are different from us.
Our colleagues are different from us.
Have the time
to maybe ask them questions
about their background,
about their cultures, you know,
maybe what kind of music they listen to.
What was the story
of that artist that they really like
from Senegal,
and just learn about them.
So, ask questions
that show that you really actually care
about them as a person
and what's unique about them.
Because when you ask questions,
then you learn
and then you develop that connection
and understanding.
And who knows,
it deepens your friendship
or your working relationship,
whatever the relationship maybe.
And also, watch documentaries,
read up about those.
So many different ways to explore
and understand and learn
without going anywhere.
And do you really think
that watching documentaries
and exploring online
without having that personal connection,
is that enough?
Well, I'm talking about in a pandemic,
thing in a pandemic,
you can speak on Zoom,
you can interact with people
all over the world on the Internet.
That's why the Internet
has been very useful.
One thing I'd like to mention about
the Internet is,
my warriors are on Facebook.
And they messaged me all the time.
Now, when they first started calling me
and Skyping me
and sending me email, I mean,
I was like," Wow."
"They use email. They use the Internet.
This is so cool."
But it's a great way
of staying connected to them.
And for them,
it's a great way of teaching
the world about their culture.
Right.
And, you know,
sending their message themselves.
It gives them an authentic platform.
So, I do think we need
to make use of
all the different types of apps
and online education available to us.
However, I believe that nothing
beats human connection.
So, at the moment, I mean,
I don't want to say anything
that will make you
break the rules, broke down rules.
But after lockdown,
whenever that may be,
it would be great for you to travel
and learn about other cultures
through participation,
through observation,
through experiences.
And if you can't do that at the moment,
think about who there is at home.
Even your friends,
maybe you haven't asked them
a question that maybe you
didn't think about until now.
And if they're from a different culture,
a different background,
maybe you can go
and after this, after listening to this,
ask them those questions about them.
Maybe you'll learn something.
Who knows.
I can't wait to go
and practice this myself.
I've been thinking for a long time
about the things that I want to be doing.
And what one of those things
is using technology
to make a positive impact.
And that's on all over the world.
But it's very, very hard for me
to understand what really needs
to happen to make a positive impact
in places like, let's say,
Africa or East Asia.
And I think part of it is because
I'm not there.
It's because I'm not feeling the people.
I'm not interacting
with them on a daily basis.
So, it's hard for me,
to understand really what they need
and how we can collaborate together.
And I have to also mention that
I've been an avid participant
in Burning Man.
And one of the main points
of Burning Man is inclusion,
diversity and understanding.
And there is one rule
that you are not allowed
to be a bystander.
You're not allowed to be a spectator.
You have to participate
in whatever you do.
So, if you see something happening,
you're not allowed
to stand there and watch.
You have to actually go in the circle
and take an active part.
And that's one of the scariest,
but also most fun things for me in that.
Sarah, we have about five minutes left
and I'd love to hear from you
some more stories about
your immersive experience.
Because I want you to give me
this a taste of what I and my friends
can experience as we go
and travel the world
and immerse ourselves with these.
Where would you like to go?
Is there a place in mind you have?
Tell me a little bit about the slums.
About you coming from the United Kingdom
and immersing yourselves
in a culture that is
a little bit different, please.
Yeah. So, the first time
I ended up in the slums
in Venezuela was by accident.
And this was in Caracas.
It's the capital
and Petare is the name of the slums.
So, Petare is the largest,
most dangerous slums
in all of Latin America.
And I ended up there the first time
by accident because the road
was blocked to work.
The second time, I went undercover
to explore and investigate
what the conditions were like there
and to learn how people lived.
Now, I remember, I'm seeing
a space developed by
a group of students
from the local university there,
because they believed
by taking care of the spaces
and renovating them,
people start caring about
the said spaces and it reduces crime.
And once I was out there,
I was in these slum houses.
I was invited by a woman
who happened to be a friend
of one of the teachers.
Now, it was so bizarre because
I saw like a thousand plushies everywhere.
It was like seven different levels
in terms of how many level floors
that were in the House.
There were speakers,
and like all the latest gadgets
and tech and, you know,
computers and music systems,
everything you can think of.
I was just so confused.
Because I was thinking, how?
Right.
What they did was
they sold essential goods,
which in the main city was hard to find
because of the shortages
caused by economic crisis.
And I can't believe
I found toilet paper here
and shampoo and milk and sugar
and all these other things
you couldn't find the shop in the city.
So, I was like, "Whoa."
However, they were being sold
about three, four, five times the price.
Really?
Yeah.
And I mean, it was just,
it was just bizarre.
Like if you watch my video
on my YouTube channel,
Surviving Caracas, you'll see.
And then I do some other like
short videos with longer,
longer durations of those actual scenes.
Yeah.
It was just really bizarre.
But she was nice to me
and she offered me some food
and drink and she was just so crazy.
She wasn't really lovely.
How do you even
get to those opportunities?
How do you go from the UK and said,
"Okay. I'm going to hop on a plane
and I'm going to go to Venezuela
and I'm going to be
in one of the most dangerous places
in the world."
So, that one actually
I was offered to be,
I was offered the role
to be a journalist and anchor,
a news anchor
for an English government channel
based over there.
And I had no idea what I signed up for.
So, when I went there,
I discovered through my,
through realizing the lines
that I was expected to read on TV.
It was not a true depiction
of what was actually happening there.
So, I decided to make
a documentary undercover.
I went back, I made a documentary
about what was really happening.
And then I,
I launched that in December 2015,
just before the elections.
And the slums in Ghana,
that was interesting because
I did several stories in the slums.
I did one on petty crime
where a man was beaten up badly.
It was like blood flowing down
from his head because he refused to
fix the car properly.
Or he refused to do something
and it was just about fixing a car.
And so he was beaten up.
And then I just stopped him
and I asked him what happened.
And he told me and I said,
"Where are you going?"
And he said,
"Well, I'm going to the police station."
I said, "Okay. Can I come with you?"
He said, "Okay."
So, as I was walking
to the police station, there was,
I was watching him report the incident.
But then a man on a motorbike,
he was unconscious,
beaten unconscious,
sandwiched between two men
on this motorcycle came
and they were trying to frame the guy
who was reporting the incident.
It was bizarre, like, wow, what's this?
What's going on?
And also, I went into,
to investigate the conditions
of the brothels in the slums.
And I remember walking up
into the building
and almost falling through the roof.
Well, the floor, you know,
it was insane.
And you know, these girls,
they came to the city
from the countryside.
They had big dreams.
One of them wanted
to be a football player
because she had talent.
And she thought if she goes to the city,
she can save up money
or she can be spotted.
But that never happened.
She ended up in the brothel
and she wasn't able to leave.
And she was embarrassed to go back
because she worried
about what her parents would think.
Another one I did was, I'm investigating
illegal mining that, I don't really want
to talk about that too much.
It's like sensitive information, you know.
No, no, no, Sarah,
I have to, first thank you
for being so generous with your time
and for sharing all those experiences.
I think that one of the things
that I'm getting most inspired by
from this is
the passion and the ambition
to go and experience these for myself.
It's one thing hearing you
talk about them,
I'm sure it's a completely
different world being there
and actually immersing myself
and indulging myself
within those experiences.
That some of them sound
very uncomfortable,
some of them sound scary,
some of them sound exciting and joyful.
But overall, I think
it just sounds mind opening.
And so, thank you
for sharing that with me and thank you
for instilling within me now
this excitement, and hopefully
anyone else who's listening.
But before we leave, I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Okay, adventurous, brutally-honest.
Well, there's a hyphen in there.
Yeah.
And loving. I love to love.
I believe in love a lot.
I love that.
Sarah, thank you very, very much.
Stay safe and stay healthy.
And I can't wait to follow you
on the next places
you're going to go to the world.
And I can't wait
to watch these documentaries
because now I'm completely excited
about them.
Thank you so much, Michael.
I hope you do.
I hope you have more stories to share.
Thank you very, very much.